this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens
i get asked all the time what i would
take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance
i recommended it in fact in the four
hour body this is more than 10 years ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula on the market
it has multivitamins multi-mineral
greens complex
probiotics and prebiotics for gut health
and immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it
once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course
i focus on nutrient-dense meals to begin
with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around right now
athletic greens is giving my audience a
special offer on top of their all-in-one
formula
which is a free vitamin d supplement and
five free travel packs with your first
subscription
purchase many of us are deficient in
vitamin d i found that
true for myself which is usually
produced in our bodies from
sun exposure so adding a vitamin d
supplement to your daily routine is a
great option for
additional immune support support your
immunity gut health
and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com tim
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all
that all good things good mood good
performance good everything
seem to stem from good sleep so i've
tried a lot
to optimize it i've tried pills and
potions
all sorts of different mattresses you
name it and for the last few years i've
been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
and like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk free they'll even pick
it up from you if you don't love it and
now my dear listeners helix is offering
up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim these are not
cheap pillows either so getting two for
free is
an upgraded deal so that's up to 200 off
and two free pillows at helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim for up to 200
off so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
tim at this optimal
i can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking
can i ask you a personal question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal
[Music]
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show where it
is my job to interview and attempt to
deconstruct world-class performers from
all different avenues
all different areas of life whether it
be business military sports or otherwise
now today we have a very special guest
although he is best known as the
co-founder and first ceo of netflix
mark randolph's story has a lot more to
it his career as an entrepreneur spans
more than four
decades he's founded or co-founded half
a dozen other successful startups
including most recently looker data
sciences
which he sold to google in 2019 for 2.6
billion that's with a billion dollars
he is currently mentoring a handful of
other early stage companies and advising
hundreds of other entrepreneurs
he is also an active seed investor in
startups all over the world
author of an international best-selling
memoir and host of the brand new podcast
one of my favorite titles for a podcast
i've seen in a long time
that will never work and we're going to
talk about why
that has some relevance to a lot of his
story
in that podcast he dispenses advice
encouragement and tough love to
struggling entrepreneurs
when not surfing mountain biking or back
country skiing mark is a frequent
speaker at industry events works
extensively with young entrepreneur
programs
sits on the board of the environmental
advocacy group
number one for the planet i'm laughing
folks because i just retook that about
17 times
and shares the national outdoor
leadership schools board of trustees you
can find him
everywhere on instagram at that will
never work twitter
mb randolph with a ph facebook at mark
b randolph linkedin mark randolph and
website
where i'm sure you can find everything
markrandolph.com mark welcome to the
show well thanks tim that was quite a
mouthful and
i struggle with advocacy group as well
too so don't worry about that
too many consonants and vowels i want to
start
perhaps in a in in the mid stream of
your
chronology of sorts a little in the
earlier chapters
and that is at 21 years old so you're
kind enough to send some
some notes to me but they're
sufficiently cryptically written that i
don't know
any of the story which is perfect and
that's what i like
so this alludes to surviving on the
streets
of hartford connecticut for three days
without money watch wallet
food etc can you please tell me this
story
yeah it's an experience that probably
you wouldn't find happening today it
kind of
begins verging on something almost
illegal but i was working
at the time for a program which took
young people from urban backgrounds
uh sometimes adjudicated youth as they
call them and we used to call it hoods
in the woods
but took them out into the backcountry
to try and really stress them a little
bit and help them learn about themselves
and it was a pretty powerful experience
for them
and as the training for us they wanted
us to have an experience where we felt
similarly disoriented so that we could
understand what they were going through
and of course all of us were pretty
comfortable campers hikers backpackers
so they had to find something a little
different and the experiment they came
up with
involved taking us to an urban area and
for me it was hartford connecticut
taking away our watch and our wallet and
our id
and dropping us off um on a sidewalk at
about 10 30 in the morning and saying
we'll be back for you in three days
and they had us write a emergency phone
number on our arm with a sharpie
just and we were in our own
dog tags but cheaper exactly but listen
i would i was probably more likely to
chew my arm off than i was to call that
phone number
i was going to make it through this
thing and you know it was pretty
pretty fun for a while and then of
course you know being a 21 year old you
begin getting hungry
so your first chore is to find food and
my first tactic was it's a little
embarrassing even to say this but i
would go to the food court
and i would hover until i saw someone
get up from their plate
and walk away with food still on it and
then like a seagull
i would swoop in and finish the food on
their plate but that worked
and then i began saying listen i should
maybe cut out the middleman i wonder if
i can get some money
and i can buy my own food and i came up
with the idea that i would
panhandle for it and i thought to myself
well how hard could that be
and the answer is really hard
i don't know tim whether you've ever had
to walk up to a stranger and put your
hand out and
ask for spare change but there is
something
deep in us in our pride that makes that
really really hard and i tried for
hours before i get the courage to even
make my first ask and of course the
person just looks down and walks past
you
and you just feel like nothing but
little by little
you kind of begin to hone the ask
you know what do you say how do you
approach someone what kind of person
do you think is more likely to give you
money and after a handful of hours i
kind of had gotten the hang of it and
the interesting thing
what worked for me was
complete sincerity at the beginning i
was trying you know [ __ ] i was you
know
i've lost my wallet i had it taken from
me i was on
and after a while i just looked people
up walk to upped people and say
can you spare some change i am really
hungry
and they could see it in my eyes and see
it in my face
and that ended up being the most
effective thing and i have never
ever forgot that experience of begging
for spare change on the streets of
hartford connecticut
because as an entrepreneur it's
part of the job description that you're
always asking for money
and i just have to say that when you
have begged for spare change
on the sidewalk that asking a vc for
fifty thousand dollars is
nothing so ah
that is a great story number one number
two if you're ever
a professional wrestler or mma fighter i
think mark the seagull randolph
is a great option for you
and even as early
as the panhandling
experiment days you're already split
testing and i think we're going to come
back to that but i want to
first go to the wilderness
experiences or those types of
experiences that you alluded to
was that organization the national
outdoor leadership school or was that a
different organization
that was a different um organization
during my summers
all through late high school and
certainly all through college
i would spend three months a year
basically leading
either going on or later leading these
back country expeditions
and two months of the year i would do
them for the school called the national
outdoor leadership school and then
one month a year i would do it for an
organization called the wilderness
school
and that was the one that was actually
not done in the rockies like knowles was
but
it was done in uh down the east coast
in the berkshires and the catskills and
that was the program that was for the
adjudicated youth
where i had to do the hartford urban
immersion program
what did you take from
knowles and maybe you could elaborate a
bit on that experience
the national outdoor leadership school
what did that provide you
i mean just so to jump to the punch line
pretty much that
taught me almost everything i know about
leadership it's in a very it was a very
special
way of learning leadership and just for
some quick background for those who have
never heard of knowles
it's a leadership school but it uses the
wilderness as that classroom
and the format although course links are
different are pretty basic was they take
a handful of people
they bust you to a trail head they drop
you off
and off you go and you're out in the
mountains for 30 days
and there's no contact you're not coming
back into town
you're a self-contained group and then
you get picked up in the 30 days and the
course is done
but the learning methodology here is
each day they break the group which
might have 12 16
students into small groups three or four
and they appoint a leader
of the day and the leader of the day has
responsibility for that group
what time they're going to leave in the
morning what the route is going to be
when they're going to stop for lunch how
long the rest breaks are going to be
whether they
stop when someone's complaining about a
blister or say let's push on
and trailing behind you of course is one
of the instructors one of the
you know leaders of the whole group but
they're not saying anything they're just
watching and
trying to make sure you don't end up
being eaten by a bear or falling in a
river but
i started doing that as a student when i
was 14 years old
and this was this opportunity to have
real leadership
responsibility to make real decisions
with
real consequences but the most
incredible
part was you found out hours later
the results of your decision making you
found out what happens
if you don't leave until 10 30 or 11 in
the morning you found out what happens
if you
let the break linger for an hour and a
half for lunch you find out what happens
if you take the wrong trail
and you begin learning even more subtle
things
you learn how to communicate with your
group how to communicate with
confidence and clarity decisions about
things you're really not that confident
or clear about
when you need to ask your group for
input and when you don't
and i was learning that when i was 14
and each time you do that you're given a
bit more responsibility and i end up
coming back and being an instructor for
the school so all of a sudden
i had a higher level of leadership and
eventually i was a course leader where i
was in charge of the entire group for
the 30 days
and so for me by the time i actually
entered
the workforce became an entrepreneur
with real stakes
i had been doing those things already
for years
and it was this chance to learn
leadership by doing it
not by studying it not by talking about
it
but by actually doing it and that ended
up being the most
incredible preparation for the career
that i ended up
choosing several follow-ups here
because i'm fantasizing about uh
john rambo first blood
developing my developing my skills not
just communication but practical
wilderness skills that's partially
tongue-in-cheek but not entirely
does the national outdoor leadership
school offer
programs or extended programs so not
just a long weekend but a week or two
for adults i i remember when i was when
i was working on one of my books looking
at different
schools like boss the boulder outdoor
survival school and i'm sure
knowles if it has an adult program if
for
for an adult who would want to
experience something like this are there
options that you're aware absolutely
and because you can learn leadership at
any age
and certainly the format is slightly
different but there's courses which are
for example as short as three days
there's courses that are as long as an
entire year there's semesters
i mean the one i described is kind of
the core offering which is one month but
of course it's unreasonable to expect
a an adult who has a job and a life
to detach for an entire month so yes
there's great programs um for adults and
they're given not just in the united
states but all over the world
with varying degrees of difficulty
depending upon what your physical
appetite is for
um for that type of thing let me ask you
about communication
because you mentioned communication and
how much that
changed your communication with groups
about decisions say
throughout this entire process and it
makes me think of warren buffett
who will often say that his best
investment was in a dale
carnegie course on public speaking
because it just it puts everything else
that you do
on steroids if it's done well how did
your communication
change over time when communicating
these decisions in other words if if you
were to look at the before
shot right you have some audio of your
first maybe kind of
awkward attempts at communicating and
then you flash forward a few years and
look at the after
could you give us an example uh or
describe how those would be most
different
yes certainly you're actually very
astute to pick up that leadership is a
hugely
communications driven thing and
people are looking to you to as i said
you know communicate with some
confidence and clarity where we're going
and there's lots of ways to do that and
one of the things that experience
teaches you one of the things that
knowles
teaches you is that we all have
different leadership styles
and you have to find a leadership style
that works for you
i mean some leaders work much better by
leading from the front
so when they're communicating it's
really here is what we're going to do
but other leaders are much more
collaborative they're one of those
leaders where
it's never quite clear who's making the
decision because they're so good at
soliciting opinion
and having it come out as a group
opinion
and it's also leadership is highly
situational
if we're just going for a hike i'm more
than happy to sit and let's talk about
where we're going and where do you think
and how's everyone feeling today
but listen when the [ __ ] hits the fan
when things are really nasty when you're
high
in a peak when the weather's coming in
there is no time for that in that case
you have to shift and realize
now i have to basically say do this
now and that people recognize in my
voice
the urgency of this that there's not
time
to challenge this there's not time to
question this if we don't go now
someone's going to get hurt
i've spent pretty much my entire life
continuing to work on
communication skill you know when i look
back at
college the two most valuable classes
that i took
was a writing class and a public
speaking class
and i use both of those skills almost
every single day and i've also kind of
realized that
you never end or never finish getting
better at them
you know writing a book wow that
required all kinds of understanding of
how much more complex this was and i
ever imagined and all the things
that i had to learn and as i began
getting into public speaking six or
seven years ago where i had to do this
not in front of five or ten people
but in front of five or ten thousand
people it just steps it up incredibly
but that's what's fun i mean learning a
craft
that's that's the best so let's let's
hone in on what appears to be one of
your superpowers and certainly a craft
and that is split testing iterating how
we we talked about the panhandling
and uh as as also an aspiring busker so
not only do i want to beat john rambo
but also busker at some point he like
drums on the sidewalk for for money
anonymously pseudonymously at some point
but i see a reality show and that's
somewhere profession
oh my god is that that's tim is that tim
ferriss drumming
just if i'm if i'm looking for other
ways i can self-immolate publicly i will
definitely i'll definitely jump on more
reality television but
when did you first cut your teeth or how
did you
most effectively cut your teeth
professionally
and you can take that in any way that
you like with with
split testing in iterating and maybe you
could explain what that even means
for people who may not know the term
sure and this goes
way back uh i mean to the very roots of
entrepreneurship
you know i i i guess probably the first
thing i did was i was a i did candy
arbitrage
you know where basically you recognize
wow
i can buy a bag of candy for a dollar
with 20 pieces in it
and i can sell each of them for a dollar
at school
and once you realize that there's this
opportunity
and you jump in and that's what i did
when i was probably in
fourth or fifth grade and but the
iteration comes from
what can i get away with i mean at first
you buy it for 10 cents and sell it for
20.
then you go that was easy maybe i can
sell it for two dollars and of course it
doesn't go so well
but little by little as you keep trying
different things you hone in on the one
that actually has
the best return for you i also sold
american
seeds which is probably the closest
thing that america had to indentured
servitude
back in the 60s when i did it we
basically went door to door selling
seed packets and if you uh sold
seven or eight thousand seed packets you
could win a 15 cent whistle or something
like that
but nevertheless i was into it because
i'd go up to the door
and i'd pitch it and it wouldn't work
and then i'd have to try at the next
door
and little by little again you're trying
different things now what happens if i
say
i've put together a combo pack or if you
buy three i'll throw in a fourth for
free and each
trying all those little things to find
out which ones
work best which ones work best for you
which one works best for the product
you're trying to sell
and you know we can jump into this this
is a big piece of my life you know
before i really became a tech
entrepreneur i was a direct marketing
guy
you know junk mail direct response
television
catalogs mail order in magazine
circulation
and that is entirely about testing
things
trying different things and seeing which
ones work
which ones don't and for ones that work
what works better
so i'll share something that i don't
think i've ever shared publicly before
one people may have heard which is i in
college applied to a few different jobs
one was trilogy software
which i was very excited about didn't
get the job ultimately
the other one that i was excited about
which i
which i also did not make the final cut
for
was working at capital one capital one
for people
listening you might recognize that
associated with credit cards at the time
they were one of the most sophisticated
direct mail outfits
they were extremely analytical and
very very good at split testing and i as
someone as a kid who
had terrible insomnia and watched lots
of infomercials
was fascinated by all of this
iteration and the idea that you could
over time determine exactly what worked
and exactly what didn't
could you speak to i suppose a
credo quote of yours that is
a sharp contrast with there are no bad
ideas it is there's no such thing as a
good idea
could you speak to that and also maybe
give us
examples of some
ideas that started off really bad in
your life
well i'm not even sure where to start
with this such an overwhelming
uh collection of bad ideas
i've over time i've migrated
and i've moved from thinking oh you know
there's no such thing as a bad idea
until we oh there are some bad ideas
and now i am firmly convinced there's no
such thing as a good idea
every idea is a bad idea
no idea performs the way you expect
once you collide it with reality and the
more i learn
the more i believe that it's true and
what that has forced me to do is say
i've got to stop thinking about things
and i've got to just begin doing them
because that's the only way i'm going to
figure out
whether it's a good idea or a bad idea
and that's hard for us it's hard for
people
because people don't like to fail they
want their experiments to work
and so they do this terrible thing
where you keep it in your head where
it's safe and where it's warm and where
you can embellish it
and it's a great idea as long as it's
all imaginary
and in the safety of your head it can
you know grow
and you can add on divisions and you can
pivot it into new areas and
you've built this huge castle in your
mind
and then of course if you ever decide to
do it of course it's way too big and too
complicated to do
so it's all about taking these bad ideas
and colliding with reality as
quickly as possible and i will give you
the classic classic idea
and this is actually the netflix
beginning
and it came from when my netflix
co-founder a gentleman named reed
hastings and i
you know we're both out of work trying
to figure out
what do we do next and i knew at that
point that i was going to start another
company
and reid was going to go back to school
but he was going to
fund this startup we were going to do we
had to find the idea together
and there's a bunch of crazy ideas which
i probably should go into with you just
to give you actually i'm going to take a
second and do it if that's okay
i want to tell you some of the crazy
ideas that actually
might have been netflix because they're
examples of bad idea good idea who knows
so one of them was personalized shampoo
where and i had this great idea and i
pitched read that okay here's how it
goes reed
you're going to cut off a lock of your
hair you're going to mail it to us
and then our team of ace hair scientists
is going to
formulate a custom blend just for you
and then you're going to subscribe to it
and then reid thought that was pretty
stupid so that didn't go any further
so then the next day in the car i was
carpooling to work with him i go okay
here's the next one custom dog food
we're going to formulate a custom blend
just for your pet
for its breed and its gender and its
activity level or its climate or
whatever
and he didn't like that either and then
the other one was video rental
by mail that wasn't quite as bad because
video rental was a
six billion dollar category but the
problem was this is 1997
video rental was on vhs cassette you may
remember it was big and awkward
and expensive and we bagged that one and
now here's the
thing i was talking about about good
ideas bad ideas
we one day heard about this technology
called a dvd
and we were in the car talking about
dvds and it's small and it's light and
it's thin
and then the idea popped in our head
that maybe
we could mail dvds to people that this
might dust off that old video rental by
mail idea
but rather than saying what a good idea
let's do some research
rather than rushing to the office and
working on a business plan
rather than you know putting together a
pitch deck
we just turned the car around
mid-commute and drove
back down to the town we lived and tried
to buy
a dvd and of course there weren't any it
was in test market so he bought a used
music cd and mailed that to reed's house
in santa cruz for the price of a postage
stamp
and the next morning we learned is it a
good idea or a bad idea because
he had gotten this cd that had got to
his house in less than 24 hours for the
price of a postage stamp
and that was a way of knowing is it a
good idea or a bad idea
and i have seen that play out a thousand
if not a thousand a million times
we are constantly surprised the one you
think is great is terrible
the one you think is uh terrible is
great it's impossible to know until you
try it
so personalized shampoo custom dog food
were there any non-negotiables
or non-negotiable aspects
characteristics
of the ideas that you brainstorm so for
instance listening to just the very
short list
one of the questions that popped into my
mind was what percentage
of these businesses that you're
brainstorming
were based right like were they was that
a prerequisite
were there any prerequisites or was it
all
just blank slate i think you've touched
on one of the
greatest ironies of the entire netflix
story i think
yes there was absolutely prerequisites
and just to
back up the story of a hair i mentioned
earlier that i had spent 15
20 years as a direct marketing guy
you know i had done everything in direct
marketing i had done catalogs i'd done
mail order i'd done
magazines circulation another
subscription business
and so it went in 1996
97 the internet was just starting to
take off
and there was this little company called
amazon which was actually starting to
show some promise in selling
books i immediately immediately
saw that this was incredible this was
direct response on steroids
this was the most incredible tool for
someone who's a direct marketer
and so one prerequisite absolutely was
i was going to do e-commerce one of
these ideas it had to involve
selling something on the internet the
second prerequisite as you probably
picked up from the personalized shampoo
custom dog food another one was custom
sporting equipment like bats or
surfboards
was that i wanted it to have a high
degree of personalization
i mean i had been at the cutting edge
of direct mail personalization but that
was
lame that was the best we could do was
dear tim ferriss won't all your friends
and neighbors at
27 you know crescent circle it was just
so
so ridiculous and i immediately saw that
with the internet we could create a
custom
page just for you so that was the
prerequisite
and yes i wanted subscription
i wanted a recurring revenue business
model i wanted to sell once
and then just fight to deliver a product
everyone wanted to keep
and this great irony is that
netflix started without subscription
i thought there's no possible way i can
do a subscription business
in video rental by mail but it was so
compelling
on the other dimensions it was so
compelling in terms of personalization
in terms of what we could do as an
online site
relative to what a bricks and mortar
store like blockbuster could do
that i decided this was worth pursuing
even though it didn't have subscription
and just to get the punch line here
the reason that the book was called
that'll never work the reason that the
blog is called that will never work is
because that is what every single person
i pitched that idea told me
you know my investors my employees my my
wife
told me that'll never work and they were
right it didn't work
and it took us a year and a half of
one failed experiment after another one
test after the next
and the thing that eventually turned it
around was subscription
i'm kicking myself even now yeah you
guys had due dates
late fees it's all a la carte absolutely
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008
crisis you would have missed out on 50
percent five zero percent of your
returns
don't miss out on the best days in the
market stay invested
in a long-term automated investment
portfolio wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees
and lower your taxes takes about three
minutes to sign up
and then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your risk appetite and manage
it for you at an incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio
day in and day out so you don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay
on your investment gains their newest
service is called autopilot and it can
monitor any checking account for excess
cash to move into savings or an
investment account they've really
thought
of a ton they've checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride
let the professionals do the work for
you go to wealthfront.com
tim and open a wealthfront investment
account today and you'll get your first
five thousand dollars managed for free
for life that's wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today at wealthfront.com
tim
you iterated what did the approach to
iteration look like in other words did
you
have a system i think a lot of people
test but it's in a pretty ad hoc way
maybe they keep good records maybe they
don't
how did how did you approach
these tests over a year and a half
well it evolved and it evolved
pretty quickly you know we launched this
great excitement it was
april of 1998 so you know 23 years ago
wow and almost immediately realized
there was good news and there was bad
news and you know the good news was we
had a
100 000 month but it was all selling
dvds and that was kind of almost this
last almost an afterthought of selling
dvds
and the rental was suck sucking wind we
were doing about two percent of our
revenue in rental because nobody would
do it
and we go okay we got to try some new
things to try and
unlock this rental business and the
problem wasn't
that i didn't have
ideas of things i wanted to try i had
tons of ideas
the problem is that back then i was a
bit of a perfectionist
and so the tests we'd put together would
be these many works of art
we'd do custom photography or we would
like
lovingly craft and argue all the copy we
would
you know spell check it and have copy
editors review it and we would stress
test the site and check every link
and as you can imagine that would take
you know two weeks to put together
and then the test would fail and we'd
look at each other and say we just
wasted two weeks
and we'd say okay faster and we'd cut
some corners
and do a test a week and it would fail
and then we'd cut some more corners and
we begin to do a test every other day
and then pretty soon to test
every day and soon we were doing four
and five
tests in the same day and
as you can imagine they're getting
pretty sloppy
by then you know there's misspellings
there's the wrong image the watermark is
still in it we're crashing the site and
the links don't work
i mean it is so sloppy but
this learning it was incredible because
we realized
it didn't make a difference that no
matter
how crappy this test was that
it was still going to surface things so
in other words if it was a bad idea even
these beautiful
two-week tests didn't make it a good
idea
but if we had stumbled on something
interesting even with these
unbelievable mistakes and crashed sights
and dead links
people still would raise their hand they
would shine the spotlight they would
call us they would come to the door and
then you saw
as plain as day what was working and
what you had to then fix
and it always surprised us and so
this insight informed everything from
then on and this insight was that it was
not about
having good ideas it was about
building this system and this process
and this culture for testing
lots of bad ideas and
netflix has never turned back from that
i've never turned back from that
i've realized that the key to being
successful
is not how good your ideas are it's how
good you
are at being able to find quick cheap
and easy ways to try your ideas
that's what i look for now entrepreneurs
that's what sets apart the good ones
from the mediocre ones
so let's let's double click on that
because this is exciting territory
so if we if we just grab sort of an
analogous
let's say it's a comparison it's a
metaphor choose your word but in the
world of science
scientific research the scientific
method really it's like science per se
isn't this kind of uh god with a
with a lab coat on but the scientific
method is a way of testing hypotheses
but
the scientific method itself doesn't
generate good
hypotheses right there's so there's
there's something to be said for
certain assumptions that are made
certain assumptions that are tested that
come
up then with the ideas or the statements
to be tested
and when i'm listening to you describe
this story
i would imagine there are many
entrepreneurs who
after a period of time when they look at
their revenue breakdown
and they see 98 percent dvd
sales 2 dvd rentals they say you know
what
great we're gonna double down on dvd
sales because that is the signal we are
getting that is the
product market fit that we are seeing
and they would have become the
i don't remember the exact name of the
columbia records or these various
outfits that would sell
music by mail right so you'd become the
equivalent or sort of the amazon of
of dvd sales why didn't you do that
you know doing a startup is kind of like
riding a mountain bike downhill
which you've got to spend like 95
percent of your time
staring five to ten feet in front of you
but every so often you've got to look up
and see where you're going
and we were basically struggling to hang
on
to doing that hundred thousand dollar
first month but every time you looked up
you did not like what you saw
amazon which right then was just selling
books
had made no secret of the fact that they
wanted to be the everything store
and we knew that the next category they
was going to go into was
music and movies we knew that pretty
soon once dvd
got a foothold that walmart would begin
selling dvds that kmart would begin
selling dvds that petsmart would sell
dvds that everybody
would be selling dvds and we didn't
think we could
or want to compete and was essentially
going to be a commodities business
so the challenge was wow
how do we get out of this
how do we have jump from a dead end
business which is
paying all of our salaries so we can
ride it for a while but how we
ultimately going to make the rental part
successful because that's the only one
which we think we can sustainably
maintain and the challenge here
was doubly bad because doing both things
at the same
time was really nasty i mean selling
and renting was confusing to customers
it was really hard to describe what we
did clearly
and operationally it was complicated i
mean the checkout process
was really complicated our metrics and
analytics were all confused
the warehousing the inventory and the
insight that came here was that
we couldn't do both that if we were
going to be successful we had to pick
one of them and so the challenge for us
was like which one and as you mentioned
the temptation the easy path was
basically to say well let's uh
stick with sales it's paying 98 of our
revenue we'll figure it out
but on the other hand if we could get
rental to work
that could be a huge business and one
that we could probably own because it
was so
operationally complex because the
margins were so good
and it points to this other incredibly
important attribute for entrepreneurship
besides this predisposition to action
that i was talking about earlier
which is courage you have to have
the willingness and the confidence to
walk away from sure mediocrity
to bet everything on the long shot
of a big success and that's just
balls you've got to say i'm gonna bet we
can figure this out and so let's
let's bet and in netflix's case
you know we did that we almost six
months in
decided that all the things that were
happening with sales was just making it
harder and so we stopped
in a single day and walked away from 98
of our revenue and said if we're going
to make it we're going to make it as a
rental company
was part of that predicated on thinking
of
your now this is not quite the right
term but kind of
exit strategy and the type of business
you are building
in in so much as thinking about kind of
go big or go home this is either going
to be a publicly traded company or it's
going to be zero this is not a lifestyle
business we don't want a lifestyle
business therefore
we're going to bet on this we're going
to bet on that two percent we're going
to bet that we can turn that into 100
and was any of that predicated on the
possible outcomes that you had
seen as your menu of options that's
really
i wish i could have wish you could have
seen
my face as you were asking that question
because i sincerely don't think i
ever had ever crossed my mind one way or
the other
seriously i never was thinking oh
there never was an exit strategy i never
at netflix or any of the other preceding
startups that i did
thought about that this was all about
solving a really
interesting problem and
the path to solving that really
interesting problem
led through having to be willing to walk
away from the sales because that was not
helping us solve the big problem
there are realities to the business of
course
you you need financial permission to
keep going
but i certainly wasn't thinking oh
mediocre success could be a nice
lifestyle business
it was more that i was caught up
in the excitement and intellectual
stimulation of saying
wouldn't it be incredible if we could
figure out a new model using the
internet
to be a better way for people to rent
movies um and that's what i thought
about
every morning when i came to work that's
what i thought about all day that's what
i thought about when i went home
that doesn't lend itself to thinking oh
i could probably get out easy here
or i could return money the investors
and go home
never part of the plan how did you think
about
naming the company what were some of the
best
worst ideas that you or anyone else has
yeah
you know naming a company
is brutally hard because the criteria
for a good name has a lot of elements to
it i mean for one you would like
something that was evocative of what you
were trying to do
you want it to be easy to spell you want
it to have the dot com
available and maybe the dot biz and
whatever the other
possible things you want to make sure
you can also get alternate spellings
you want to make sure it doesn't mean
some terrible obscenity in lithuanian
you know you want to make sure you get a
trademark you want it now you need to
make sure can i get the twitter handle
can i get snap can i get ticked i mean
you need to
cover all these bases and it's really
hard now and it was really hard then and
it's so hard
that well so when you start when you
found the company when you actually
incorporate you say okay now i've got to
begin paying people i need to have
checks i need to enter into contracts
you're not ready to go through that huge
uphill battle to figure out your name
you just come up with what's called a
beta name it's the name you're going to
use while you're kind of
getting ready to launch and our beta
name
at netflix this is kind of little
netflix trivia was actually called
kibble
we were kibble.com like the dog food
you've been in you'd been infected by
the custom dog food i did yeah that's
great well
yeah and i just happened to own kibble
probably because i was so excited about
the uh
custom dog food idea and it and but the
thing is
when i had a i had a person who was one
of my early investors at netflix as a
matter of fact but on a board but also a
friend of mine who i had done a startup
with in the past
who gave me the advice he said mark when
you're picking your beta name
pick something so bad that when you
finally get to the point you're trying
to pick your real name
and you're really struggling you won't
be tempted
to use your beta name so
that was the other advice so that's good
so we were struggling as of course we're
getting to the end you know we're
getting probably only at two or three
weeks away from launch
and we still don't have a name and so we
go okay we're gonna have to force this
one
and we got everyone in a conference room
and we on a whiteboard made two columns
and one we brainstormed every possible
word that was evocative of the internet
you know net and web and e
and in the other column we brainstormed
words that were evocative of video or
rental
and then began drawing all the you know
the criss-crossing lines between them
and you know some of them were i thought
pretty good my favorite actually was
replay.com which i thought oh that's
pretty cool
but um replay was available but it cost
forty thousand dollars and they may as
well
quoted me 40 million dollars at that
point that i wasn't going to pay 40 000
for a domain name another one was
cinemacenter.com
and then we had all the other variations
we had web flicks we had netflix with us
cks
we had you know all these crazy names
and netflix was
far and away no one's favorite and i
don't know whether you remember this tim
but back in the
you know in the 60s and 70s the
nickname for porno used to be a skin
flick
or skin flicks and everyone's going oh
we can't call it flicks
and that x that x is even worse
but you know after a while you're going
on the list and you go i can't get the
domain name i can't get the trademark
this is already being used in canada and
then finally you go okay listen we gotta
make a decision and
you know netflix was a a little porny
but it was the best we could do
and i just want to underscore one thing
you said that's really important
likely at least at the time available as
a trademark across the board
right domestically and internationally
if you look at something like replay.com
or even netflix with the cks you can
stretching a little bit here but you can
get into kind of
descriptive murky territory
and like you said there are these check
boxes that are really important to
look at very closely a friend of mine
because we're recording this during
the gamestop mania and excitement you
know a friend of mine was thinking of
using
the sort of wsb wall street bets etc for
a sort of spin-off business of sorts and
and he was about to put a bunch of money
into developing and i said before you do
that
make sure you go to uspto.gov take a
look at who owns
any trademarks and you may just dodge a
massive bullet which you
which you ended up doing so netflix so
we have netflix
now you've invoked a name and the name
is
is one of the demigods maybe even a
major not lesser god of e-commerce
and that is jeff bezos so less than a
year into
this netflix little pony but effective
journey
you get you get a call from none other
than
uh jeff bezos inquiring about
potentially buying the company
can you tell me about your trip to
seattle
or anything else about that exchange but
you've got to understand
how it felt for me to get a call from
jeff bezos
i mean this was two things first of all
this was the idea that
everybody said that'll never work this
is the idea that
no one had confidence in and to get a
call from
jeff bezos i mean the pioneer
the king of e-commerce oh my gosh the
validation
it was like okay someone at least not
just someone not just anyone
but jeff bezos sees potential in this
so it was this tremendously exciting
moment
and you know when he called he was a
little
cagey it was like you know listen i'd
love to come on up to seattle i'd love
to meet you guys let's just come on up
and we'll
get acquainted so he didn't come out
right out and say he wanted to buy the
company
but it didn't take um you know rocket
science to figure out that's what this
meeting was going to be
about as i mentioned earlier they were
just books at that point
and we knew that video or music or both
was next on the list and so
it was pretty sure that netflix was a
candidate to be a make or buy evaluation
in other words maybe you could jump
start into video by buying us
so reid and i flew up to seattle and
this is pre um you know pre-waze and
pre-google maps
we had printed out um the map from a
site called map quest
map quest i knew it was coming yeah if
you can remember those days
and and i was so sure that reed had
[ __ ] this up if you'll pardon me
uh because we were in we were in a
pretty sketchy part of town
i mean we're walking past this broken
glass on the sidewalk there's people
sleeping in the doorways there's
hypodermic needles there's sex shops and
i i go there's no way that
the pioneers of e-commerce are
here but yes you turn the corner
and there in this old warehouse-y
building
through these dusty plate glass windows
i could see in and see that there was a
sign
lo and behold amazon and we'd go in
and it's you can't picture this because
it is
jammed to the gills with people and
dogs and pizza boxes and
printers stacked on top of piles of
books
and people are crammed in five or six to
a cubicle
they get ushered into this conference
room and the conference table
is four doors that are
obviously not in doorways they're on saw
horses
we pushed together to be a conference
table and in fact
as you're walking in we had noticed that
every single person was working
at a desk made out of a door
and it was wow this is pretty crazy and
we had this great conversation because
jeff and i kind of were
totally riffing on this excitement
of starting these companies and he was
talking about
when he had rigged up a bell that would
ring every time an order came in
which is exactly what we had done so we
had this kind of opening day
excitement stories to tell but of course
we got down to business and in fact
yes they were interested in perhaps
using netflix to jump start
into video and they talked to us
understood everything and on the way out
we had the cfo
of amazon exported us out and kind of
did the hints
she goes you know in the event this
happened was to set expectations
it's probably going to be in the 10 to
15 million dollar range
and that wouldn't have been
so bad for something i've been working
on
for less than 12 months you know and at
the time i owned 40 percent of the
company
but it was really interesting
what reid and i talked about in the
flight home because
again this is the company that everyone
had said will never work
but we had managed to put together an
e-commerce website
we had managed to find a copy of every
single dvd available at the time
we had forged these partnerships with
all the dvd player manufacturers that
were bringing us in customers
and it felt like at that moment that
we had got it all figured out and
we kind of looked at each other and said
i don't think we're ready
to hand someone else the keys um and so
in some ways this wasn't a trip up to
sell the company
or maybe the trip up was to sell a
company but on the way back
it felt more like a commitment ceremony
where we kind of had to look each other
in the eyes and say
are we in or are we not in and uh
i think luckily for the rest of the
story um
we were in so you're
you've you've described the flight out i
would love to hear you
talk about the flight in and
maybe it's part of this extends to well
before that but
how did you prepare for or strategize
for
the amazon meeting oh
the the depths of and and the reason i
ask in part
sorry to interrupt you and me both but
part of the reason i ask is that you
mentioned a term that i think is really
important
and that is the buyer build
decision right so amazon can use you to
jump start
their video business but they could also
choose to build it themselves and
sometimes big companies i'm not saying
this is what amazon did
but sometimes big companies will invite
smaller companies in
to have them open the kimono so to speak
and share lots and lots and lots and
lots of details
sometimes under cover of due diligence
so they can then go ahead
and just build everything a lot faster
internally right that does happen i'm
not saying with amazon but it does
happen
so i'd love to hear how you guys
prepared for this meeting
so you know i'd been in silicon valley
for 10 years by that point
i knew that was certainly one of the
components
of someone someone's interest i knew
there was
always the chance that they'd just pick
our brains and do it themselves
and so that navigation wasn't
particularly tricky
because we knew going in what to expect
but i much prefer to be pretty
forthcoming
and i've always believed it's
better to assume good about people
than to protect myself from bad i'm
willing to get burned
because normally it works better for me
if i go in being vulnerable and honest
but the real story of the preparation
you know i laughed when you mentioned
that because
it really is in some ways maybe it's a
flaw
of mine but but the best is that i am a
ridiculous over preparer for important
things in my life and just to give you a
really quick example of this
from way earlier in my life you know i
was a second baseman
when i was playing high school baseball
which is the that was the basically the
end of my baseball career as far as i
got
but i thought i was a pretty good high
school second baseman
and one of the jobs of a second baseman
is to back up
first base when a throw goes to first
and there was one particular game where
all of a sudden
a throw came to first base and missed
first base
and amazingly enough i happened to be
back there
and snagged the ball and threw the
runner out at second
and when i came in you know the coach
it was going that was amazing
how did you know to be back there for
that play
and it was puzzling to me because i said
i am
back there every pitch i run behind set
first base every pitch
and that's how i treat these kind of
negotiations i'm ready for pretty much
anything i think deeply about what could
this meeting be about
what are the questions they're going to
ask what do they really want to know
what are the best way to position our
company favorably what do i need to
understand about amazon to make the
decision about whether i might want to
have the company sold to them
and then i go through what my answers
might be
and of course you've prepared a hundred
different answers and you only end up
using eight of them
but that's okay that just means that it
comes off more
more positively for you don't try this
at home folks
yeah yeah so that'll never work you
heard it over and over again from
possible sources of financing
from everybody left and right with
respect to netflix what were the biggest
things that people missed or got wrong
in terms of assumptions about netflix
that led them to conclude that'll never
work and i'll give just a quick example
with
say uber for instance early on they were
turned down by everybody for financing
just about because it was assumed that
whatever market they had their total
addressable market it was a fraction of
whatever the current
on-demand black sedan
car service market was and that was an
incorrect assumption
because ultimately uber black ended up
funding the r d and subsidizing what
later became uberx
and before you know it the market
expands exponentially so what
what were people missing or getting
wrong that led them
to say that'll never work there was two
reasons that almost everybody drew on to
conclude that'll never work
and the first was blockbuster
that here we were this tiny little
upstart
everyone said blockbuster is the problem
and
that just makes sense because
blockbuster at the time
had 9 000 stores they had
60 000 employees they were doing six
billion dollars in revenue
and the thought that we could get a
foothold against that
and worse it wasn't just getting a
foothold against a bigger company
it was basically saying we're proposing
a model
where you come to the internet and you
order a movie
and we mail it to you and it's going to
take anywhere from
one to four days for that movie to
arrive
and people could not get their hands
around how that could possibly work
when you could pretty much throw a stone
from any place in the united states and
hit a blockbuster why would anybody do
it through you when they could just
drive
five minutes and rent from blockbuster
and
they had a point we did have some things
up our sleeve
basically the fact that everyone hated
blockbuster
you always want to compete against
someone that everyone else hates
but we also why did they hate
blockbuster blockbuster
the part of it was blockbuster's
attitude
uh blockbuster did not believe
that they were in the customer service
business
and so people were frustrated with the
experience
they also relied in their business model
on late fees uh
late fees oh i remember that in fact
they actually had an
internal term for it and they called it
managed
dissatisfaction and
oh my god that's great and you always
want to compete with someone
whose core tenant is managed
dissatisfaction
they also had a problem that because
they weren't they were really in the
demand fulfillment side
that they had this new release issue
where
a new release would come out and
people like lemmings would all flock to
the blockbuster and they would all
want the same movie and of course
blockbuster can't afford
to buy enough copies to satisfy every
single person who wants it on day one
because their whole model is you buy it
once
and then you turn it 20 or 30 times
and so what they have to do is basically
say we're gonna have
a lot of people not getting the movie
they came in for
and that will force them to come back
again and run it next week or the week
after so they can get the turns out of
it
so all these things were fundamentally
frustrating
to customers and and discovery
you know the reason that everyone
flocked to new releases
was it was so hard to find something
else to watch
that you would do that if you may
remember this you go to the store
and you basically begin doing this
pacing like
a tiger you see at the zoo up and down
each aisle
just hoping something leaps out at you
that you haven't seen before
that you've heard of that you want to
watch and so you naturally gravitate to
the new release wall not because
they're better movies because it's a
higher percentage
of movies you haven't seen yet anyway
lots and lots of reasons we go this
should be disruptable but blockbuster
was just one reason
the other reason everyone said that'll
never work was the fact that the dvd was
digital
it was a digital medium and everyone
said well just a matter of
time months before this movie can be
downloaded
or streamed who's going to want to
get it on dvd when they can just stream
it to their house
and they were right about that latter
one
you know we thought they were wrong
about the timing
that it would be a long shot if it was
going to happen in a few months we
thought it was going to be years
but nonetheless both of those were very
reasonable objections about why
this business would never work and we
really had to attack both of those
if we were going to be successful so you
invoked
darth vader in this particular in this
particular movie
blockbuster and although the story of
blockbuster is also kind of amazing i
mean just you know
huizenga and the entire the entire arc
of that is just
amazing in and of itself but two years
in the perfect storm of bad news
as i have it here led you to fly not to
amazon but to dallas
to try to sell netflix to blockbuster
what happened there what was the bad
news
and how did that trip to blockbuster go
these stories have such twists and turns
and ironic moments you know we started
we spoke earlier um
in our conversation about the um
the struggle to find the as they say
repeatable scalable business model
how when we launched it didn't work how
we had to figure out how to get rental
to work and how we struggled for a year
and a half
and that eventually the thing that
worked was this completely irrational
combination
of things one of them as i mentioned
before was subscription
but the other thing was that one day i
was in our warehouse
and at the time we probably had several
hundred thousand dvds in the warehouse
and i remember looking around at these
full shelves
and thinking what a shame they're doing
us no good sitting on the shelf i wonder
if there's some way to store these
movies at our customers houses
let them just keep them and maybe they
do i don't know peer-to-peer exchange
maybe they keep it as long as they want
when they want another one they mail it
back and we'll replace it
and that idea when combined
with subscription was worth a test
and when we tested it finally you know
after a year and a half it worked
and it worked remarkably well it took
off
i mean people were signing up in droves
thousands a week
for this new no due dates no late fees
subscription video rental program now
that's a great story but as you may know
about
the subscription business it has some
great things about it and some bad
things about it
and the great thing about it is it's
recurring revenue
once you've acquired that customer if
you take good care of them
they pay you month after month after
month for
years if you do a good job the downside
is
all the acquisition cost takes place up
front
all the money you spend on marketing and
fulfillment
and customer service to get that
customer
is out the door and it's usually a
number
way in excess of how much they pay you
that first month
it takes having to be a customer for six
to 12 months or even longer sometimes to
recover that marketing expense
so when orders are flooding in the door
on one hand you're going this is
fantastic but it also means that money
is flying out the door
and that is not so fantastic
and it's especially not so fantastic
when you get to april
of the year 2000 when all the wheels
suddenly come off the cart
of the dot-com bubble if i can mangle
two metaphors there sorry but
in other words what had been easy in
march
basically we just go outside the netflix
headquarters we'd wave the green flag
and the
big dump truck full of money would back
up and dump it into the driveway and
we'd send everyone out with the
wheelbarrows to bring the money in
all of a sudden you get to april and the
drivers are putting their head down and
averting their eyes and speeding past
you there is not a cent to be had
especially not for a company with dot
com in its name
so we're desperate we have finally
cracked the code
we're succeeding but we're going
bankrupt in our success
and that was probably the lowest moment
and we breed and i looked at each other
and basically decided this is the time
to as they
refer to it time to pursue strategic
alternatives
which is the silicon valley expression
for basically you've got to sell this
sucker you know and fast
and the obvious strategic alternative at
the time was of course blockbuster
um but you know they were huge they were
six billion dollars in revenue we were
five million dollars in revenue and we
were 100 employees and they were
60 000 employees so you know we tried
getting this meeting
nothing you know wouldn't return the
calls we'd respond to the emails
so this is all preamble to this meeting
with blockbuster but it's
such a crazy story the time they chose
to call
happened to be we were doing this
corporate retreat at a place called the
alisal ranch which is in the foothills
outside of santa barbara
and as you can imagine it's pretty
casual
uh because not only is we're casual at
work so when you go to a retreat you got
to work at it
and i had brought nothing but t-shirts
and flip-flops and shorts
and that's when they call and say we'd
love to see you tomorrow morning in
dallas
and we're looking at each other and
going there is no way
we can't get from this ranch in santa
barbara
to dallas by tomorrow morning and so we
did the thing that you would prudently
do when you're
many millions of dollars in the hole
which is we chartered
a corporate jet to fly us to dallas
oh this is perfect i'll share with you
one more piece of netflix trivia
so that jet was owned by vanna white
okay didn't see that coming either but
anyway we fly to dallas we end up
being ushered up into this big 17 or 18
story
blast and steel skyscraper and they
bring us into this conference room
which is the size of a football field
and this beautiful
endangered hardwood conference table
and i remember sitting there going oh my
god every place has like
paper and a pen and there's they've got
extra office supplies
this this is something and then income
the blockbuster
guys and they're in their very expensive
clothes and
you know alligator shoes it which is in
contrast to me
who's in a t-shirt and shorts and
flip-flops
i was jealous because reed had on a
hawaiian shirt
he had buttons but anyway
we make our pitch and
we're going to combine forces that we
will run the online part of the business
blockbuster will run the stores we laid
out
all the incredible synergies that come
from having this blended model business
and then we'd all live happily ever
after
and it was going great you know they
were they were leaning in
they were asking good questions uh and
then they asked
of course the obvious question which is
how much how much are we going to pay
for you guys
and we had obviously rehearsed this one
on the plane
so reed screwed up his courage and kind
of leaned in and said
50 million dollars
and they laughed at us
i mean maybe not out loud
but i swear john antiocho is like
trying to hold back um a laugh
and as you can imagine the meeting went
downhill pretty quickly after that
and it was this long quiet ride in the
cab back to the airport an even
quieter ride back to santa barbara on
the plane
and it was a crushing moment
because we had finally gotten this
meeting
it was self-evident to us that this
blended model of online and stores
could be an incredibly powerful force
and blockbuster hadn't seen it
and so now rather than
this being the you know as i say in the
movies the deus ex machina moment where
the heroes are backed up against the
cliff and the indians are
lining the cliffs and there there's
sudden death
and all of a sudden in comes the cavalry
and plucks them to safety
but unfortunately not only was
blockbuster not going to save us
blockbuster was going to compete with us
and wow that was sobering
and as we got back and
said to ourselves what's going to happen
it was this realization that this was
one of those problems that there wasn't
going to be a shortcut
there was not an easy way out there was
not something we missed
that you know as my dad used to say to
me sometimes you know mark sometimes the
only way out
is through that we're going to have to
confront this
head on and take on blockbuster
and you know it took us i don't know 10
plus years
but eventually you know the company that
had 9 000 stores is down to one
and the company they could have bought
for 50 million dollars is now worth 250
billion dollars
it's such an amazing turn
when i think back to that moment to
where netflix is
today but tim the amazing thing here is
that when i tell that story to people
there's this dichotomy of reactions
because for the people who are the
entrepreneurs they're going oh this is
so inspiring
you know like a handful of people with
no experience in the video industry took
down a
six billion dollar company but sometimes
i tell that story to corporate audiences
and for them
it's a very different message because
then it's basically
you have no idea who's coming after you
and they're going to come after you not
doing the thing you do well
they're going to come after you doing
the thing poorly or you don't do it all
or you're scared to do watch out for the
people you consider rounding hers
as uh as uh one yahoo executive said to
a friend of mine alexis ohanian who
co-founded reddit
he said oh you guys are around her in a
meeting looking at their traffic
didn't turn out so well for free i love
that question i have
so so i can see it from from a number of
different perspectives
and first question i'd like to ask is
related to your reputation for not
accepting no as an answer
right so i'm trying to zoom in because
hindsight 2020 of course it makes an
excellent story but there are lots of
startups that go out of business
there are lots of startups that don't
survive the existential
threats and the economic meltdowns they
just do not make it through
so when i go back to that point in time
you guys offer or suggest propose 50
million
they basically laugh why didn't you keep
dropping the price until you found a
price they would accept
i'm not saying you should have done that
i'm just wondering it must have
been a whole mix of emotions
why not look for the soft landing
at a lower price or find a price that
would finally be a yes
i think there was a couple of things
we hadn't picked 50 million dollars at
random
on one hand it had no
underpinnings in valuation
this wasn't based on multiples of next
12 months
revenue or anything that you'd normally
use to value a business that you were
trying actively to sell
it was based on two things it was based
on number one we had raised 50 million
dollars to date
and has spent most of it and this was a
way for reid and i
to make our investors whole and that
if it was going to be dramatically less
than that
we were less interested the other one
was the reasoning we thought that would
make 50 million dollars reasonable
was not what was netflix worth to
someone as an
ongoing netflix but what would it be
worth
to blockbuster to their 6 billion
dollars in revenue to have
a team of people who were deeply
involved in the technology of video
rental
which quite frankly blockbuster wasn't
and so we thought
that them recovering their investment
many times over
purely by getting a small bump in the
six billion
revenue would make it work but
the neither of those reasonings for them
resonated
and so i don't think this was a question
of well maybe 40 maybe 35.
i think they would have gone back to
some cash flow analysis or some
next 12-month revenue and that would
have been dramatically dramatically less
sufficient that it wasn't worth us
recovering
pennies in the dollar for investor
better for us to say well screw it let's
uh
let's prove these guys wrong so next i
want to bring up
i would love to hear you explain
something that i see referred to as the
canada principle
now i'm just gonna i wanna i wanna read
a line here which is from it's on
bgr.com but this is a quote from you
please feel free to correct me if i'm
wrong
i'd certainly be extremely surprised to
ever see ads on netflix only because
netflix is so focused on the canada
principle
what in the hell is the canada principle
so
the canada principle when you're
starting out
as we were in the united states and
you're starting to get a little bit of
traction so this may be where
we're past the blockbuster thing our
subscription no due dates no late fee
programmers doing gangbusters and
people say you should go into canada
that'd be an easy 10 bump in your
revenues
because you know canada is approximately
10 percent the market size of the united
states
at first you go well that's kind of
interesting yeah that'd be a pretty easy
way just to get a quick 10
but then you begin to think about it and
you go i'm not quite so sure about the
easy
i mean for one they do have a different
currency
some of our dvds have different rights
arrangements in canada than they do here
there's this little issue of
language that part of canada actually
speaks french
and in fact legally mandates that the
materials are in french as well as in
english
and you begin accumulating all these
small things
which under some circumstances you might
go that's not a bad price to pay for an
additional 10
bump in your revenue but what we
realized is we were growing
so quickly at that point that were we to
take the exact same effort as minimal as
it might be that it took to get into
canada
and just apply it back on our core
business
we would get a way bigger bump than 10
and what the canada principle really
says is
you've got to focus that the real key is
picking the two or three things
that are the most important that if you
get those right nothing else matters
and allocate all of your resources to
that
and you have to very very consciously
choose not to do things which appear
easy
you've got to say oh oh there's netflix
clones launching in the uk should we
enter the uk to try and
stamp them out to beat them to the punch
and you have to say
no we are way better taking the
distraction that would occur doing that
and doubling down and the things that
we're already good at
because that learning that acceleration
will just pay dividends down the road we
eventually do decide
to enter the uk for example but that
focus that's at the heart of i believe
what makes any startup successful is
not getting distracted we used to also
call i refer to it as
scraping the barnacles off the whole
because as you're
moving you're testing things you're
trying things and you're slowly but
surely
accreting new features to your business
and of course you have a new thing you
want to try
and all of a sudden it's got to be
reverse compatible with this
and you want to change the price but you
go wait a minute what about that small
group who have this different offer
and you have to consciously go into a
meeting wherever you discuss what you're
going to do next
at the same time discuss what are we
going to
stop doing all those things designed to
make sure you're putting
all of your attention on the things that
really matter i love that expression
the scraping the barnacles off the hull
it's so true i mean this is particularly
true
in a lot it's true in many things but
software development i mean you get paid
for adding features
or you get rewarded for adding features
as a as a programmer
a seldom rewarded for removing features
which is how you end up with
a lot of kind of bloated over featured
software one of the quotes from the same
piece that i mentioned that i really
like is these things which seem like
low-hanging fruit never
are ads are a distraction never an
additive thing
so the follow-up to that that i have for
you is what were some of the most
tempting opportunities that in
retrospect were most important to say no
to you've mentioned a couple
right canada you mentioned entering the
uk
were there any other temptations or
internal pressures anything
that in retrospect were really important
to have said no to
there was certainly the temptation to do
soft
core or adult not hardcore stuff but
adult content only because that's such a
huge
driver of new technologies and
that took some discipline to say we
don't want to get
entangled up in that and not out of any
moralistic
preaching about what's appropriate or
not appropriate but purely because being
a company which was
pretty much had customers in every
single county in the united states we
just didn't want to self leave ourselves
vulnerable to a particular district
attorney who was behind in the polls
someplace and wanted to
take down the smart alecky e-commerce
folks way back in california that was
one we
dodged early on games people talked
about we should do games
but it didn't take too much thinking to
realize that games do not have the shelf
life that movies do
able to dodge that one probably the
closest we came to getting distracted
du jour at the time which basically said
no no you're not a movie rental site
you are everything movies you're going
to your people come for show times
you're going to come to get reviews
you're going to be able to buy tickets
and we actually started on the path of
building that out
and we put in place our ipo prospectus
based on the fact that we were going to
be a portal
and when the bubble burst
in april of 2000 and we had to pull
our ipo that was such an
unbelievably lucky break because if we
had ended up going public
as a portal we would have been committed
and we never could have made
that work you know a friend of mine
i'm blanking it might be mike maples jr
has said to me
or actually i think it's brandon stan
of humans of new york fame but he said
sometimes you need life to
save you from what you want to give you
what you need
something alone something along those
lines i'm paraphrasing but
yeah sometimes those catastrophes are
lucky breaks i want to talk
about something that is a bit of a 90
degree turn
but we've been i think talking a lot
about
strategy about the business about
netflix and that's certainly
on one side of the ledger but while this
is all happening
you have a personal life to
think about to manage well
poorly or somewhere in between and i
want to read
a paragraph about tuesdays at 5 00 p.m
and then i'd love to discuss this
because this is something that my
girlfriend and i
would like to work on and here it is and
we feel free to fact check i vowed early
on i was not going to be one of those
entrepreneurs who was on his sixth
startup and his sixth
wife so we had this tradition that every
tuesday without fail 5 pm i left the
office and my wife and i did a date
night
and at first when you announced that
that's going to happen everyone goes
yeah yeah yeah sure but i was serious
if there's a crisis well we're going to
resolve by 5 pm okay you have to talk to
me great on the way to the car
fantastic things happen can you please
speak
about this decision and how you
stuck to it and implemented it because i
i know a lot of couples and
i'm part of one of them who have kind of
committed to this but then it falls by
the wayside
this happens a lot and i would love to
hear you tell your story
and share any advice that you have for
people who might want to
emulate this i've always
had my priority to be
balanced and like everyone i screwed it
up
but i was able to self-correct
right about when i turned 30.
so of course during my 20s and late 20s
i
worked like a dog and my girlfriend then
my
now my wife you know i think that was
hard on the relationship
the fact that i would go and work on
weekends
i would be there until eight or nine
o'clock at night essentially
squeezing in my relationship
in whatever spare time was left from the
business that i was working on
but i was also shortchanging not just
her i was shortchanging myself
you know my passion is
outdoors you know my passion is back
country skiing and mountain biking and
surfing and kayaking and alpine climbing
and
these are not things that you can
squeeze in between your 11 o'clock and
your 1 o'clock calls
if you want to be able to continue to do
those you've got to make space for them
and so i kind of had this moment
where i said i am not going to
lose these two important parts of my
life and began compartmentalizing
and that's when the date nights started
and it was not just netflix's other
companies prior to that
where they saw this happen and you know
people
talk all about corporate culture
and they write manifestos and they put
together
slideshows and they carve it in their
building cornerstone
but you know culture is not what you say
it's what you do and so people all
preach about we believe in balance and
take care of yourself
and then they don't act it and what was
so fascinating about me
having that discipline that at least one
night a week
i would leave at five o'clock no matter
what was going on
is that once i got through the first two
or three months of it
it got immeasurably easier because
people
stopped asking they stopped trying
to put meetings on the calendar after
five on tuesdays they realized they were
gonna have to resolve this crisis
on their own or do it before five if
they wanted me to help
and the best part the best part was that
everyone else began realizing that they
could do this
that they could not only leave at five
o'clock on tuesday because they realized
there was nothing that i was going to
drive that was going to pull them back
i was modeling how i really wanted the
culture of that company to be
and i'm still pretty busy but i still
managed to get away
and go for a five or six day back
country skiing trip i still get to fly
up to you know northern alaska and do
two weeks in the no attack river because
i make space for that and i prioritize
that space
and the things i have to get done i make
sure i get them done before i leave
and they're prepared to get picked up by
someone else while i'm gone
and then i can jump back in when i
return and
it's hard but it's important
it does not happen if you wait until
let's see if i have enough time
it only happens if you make that time
how did you
land on tuesday nights and did it start
off on a different night and just
not work to end up on tuesday
i don't remember yes it moves around
and it moves so you know the shorthand
every tuesday
is probably a little bit just making it
a simpler story
the point is it's every week and a lot
of times the babysitter can't do it on a
tuesday so fine we're going to do it on
a thursday
but it wasn't so much the discipline of
that it was the fact that this is going
to happen
and this is going to happen before
anything else gets scheduled but i would
say by and large it was tuesdays
or sometimes wednesdays could you tell a
story of a time that it was stress
tested
where there was a crisis that was large
enough or a situation
that seemed important enough where
you're like god i really it would be
it would probably be best for the
business for me to push date night are
there any
examples of how you've navigated that
that you could share
yes of course there are the founder of
knowles a guy named paul petzl
used to say rules are for fools
because in the mountains things happen
and even though
all of your processes and systems say do
it one way sometimes
you got to do it a different way and
it's also like people i know who are
really disciplined about their eating
listen once in a while you got to let
loose you've got to be able
to fall off the uh the eating well wagon
and have
you know six slices of pizza but it's
fine as long as you get
back on the next day um it's you know
one of the core principles of meditation
is that
oops i've gotten distracted let's get
back to it
so yes there were certainly
circumstances where those tuesday rules
got broken
but they were dramatically the exception
and the trick was when recognizing what
had happened
and not to have that be the camel's nose
under the tent
but to say that was a once in a long
period exception
and certainly things that happens when
netflix went public when we were
fighting for our life
with um you know with blockbuster
when there's personnel crises that i
just have to be there for
but it's certainly it's something that
my partner my best friend can understand
because she sees that the consistency is
there on the other side of it
and that if i'm saying this one time i
need to do this that i'm not just
making it up not not an excuse can you
make any recommendations
number one i i love the expression
camel's nose under the tent i've never
heard that before in my life
it sounds amazing sounds like the uh
sounds like the good title for a parable
of some type and the uh
the question i have is what advice could
you give to people who want to implement
a date night like what are some tactical
pieces of advice
or best practices recommendations for
those
who are starting off with some training
wheels they don't even know what to do
does that mean
watching a movie and eating popcorn is
it going out and having dinner let's
pretend that kova doesn't exist just for
the moment what are some of the
what are some of the things you've
learned over time any recommendations
yeah absolutely so first of all these
aren't one size fits all
this worked for my wife and i this
worked for the type of business i was in
where i was the boss
and i could do this obviously
you may not be able to do this if you
work for someone else you can't just go
i'm leaving at five o'clock thanks very
much
it's recognizing the principle behind it
and saying what would work
for me that's part one part
two is do not design
a new year's resolution with 18
different things in it
any of us who've made resolutions know
you're lucky if you can make one of them
happen
no less trying to have this aspirational
list
of all the things that you think would
be wonderful if they happened
so start small say i'm going to put my
phone away
every saturday from nine in the morning
until sunday morning
and be present and see how that feels
i mean in other words take steps which
are possible take steps that are
manageable
and then the third thing i'd recommend
is i'm a big believer
in establishing habits and this of
course has been beaten to death but
doesn't make it any less true
is that pick something and try to stick
with it
it is more important to find something
that you can
reasonably do over the long haul than it
is to make this a huge
jump but not be able to hang on to it
and it's with practice with realizing
that wow if i don't
do email all weekend the world
didn't end you know or if i say i'm
going to do it from
after five on sundays that no one
freaked out maybe i can try something a
little bit different in a few months
that's all doesn't need to be what i've
done or what worked for me it's what
works for
for you it's the principle it's that
business is secondary and i really
believe that
you know you can have all the money in
the world but if you don't have a strong
relationship or you're not
doing the things that make you happy
when you're not at work
what's the point you know let's talk
about that type of clarity and
specifically what i have down here in my
notes is a moment of clarity that you
experienced through which you found your
purpose in life so that's
that's a statement i definitely want to
unpack and that seems to have led to
writing your book and ultimately
to your new podcast what was this moment
of clarity
what was the purpose that you found
clarity around
i've had two big phases in my life
and i have to briefly have to give you
the first piece because that'll explain
what happened in the second one
and i've always believed that if
you get older you are incredibly lucky
if you find out two things two important
things about yourself
and the first is what are you good at
and the second thing is
what do you enjoy and i was remarkably
lucky
early in my life in my early 20s to
discover those things and
even more lucky that they were both the
same thing and it was
early stage stuff it was
entrepreneurship it was starting things
i love it i love that challenge i love
the problem solving i love sitting
around the table with the smart people
solving
really hard problems and here's the
immodesty
alert i'm actually really good at it
um and just because i have some of those
innate skills maybe it's from all the
direct marketing stuff maybe it's just
that i'm really good at focus
or having an innate sense of triage but
i've been incredibly lucky that i've
gotten to pursue that
for 40 years and i've started a bunch of
companies
all of which were so exciting and so fun
and two of them
which did remarkably well economically
too
and that was my purpose for the first 50
some odd years of my life and then
i had left netflix and i left netflix
back in 2002
to know 2003. so quite a while ago
and i was drifting a little bit
i mean i was pretty fulfilled because i
was mentoring other
early stage companies i was working with
entrepreneurs i was kind of getting my
fix
and then i got invited to come to
necker island which is richard branson's
you know
founder virgin billionaire his private
island
in the british west indies to come for
four days
and hang out in the beach and kite surf
and party and that's pretty special
and i said no thank you
and that decision lasted about as long
as it took to tell my wife
about it and then all of a sudden
no i'm canceling my boys mountain bike
week that i had planned for that same
time and all of a sudden we're buying
sunscreen but we couldn't
i would it wasn't all going to be this
fun and games i was going to necker
island because they wanted me to do a
40-minute presentation
on turning dreams into realities
for a conference of women successful
business owners
and the title of this conference was
finding your purpose and
i was going like to my wife i go ah
we'll go i'll do my bit and then we'll
spend
three to four days on the beach not so
bad
i went gave my speech and they decided
i'd hang out
and listen and find out what this
finding your purpose stuff is all about
and i listened to the first speaker and
then i sat down in the chair again
and then the second speaker and put my
towel under my chair
and one day led into the next to the
next and pretty much
i had realized i had dramatically
overbought on sunscreen
but it made me think what is
my purpose i was here as a speaker but
it was speaking to me
and i was going i have this amazing
platform because netflix has done
remarkably well
largely since i left for the things that
have nothing to do with me except
perhaps my dna and the foundation i
established
but because of it people will
i can get 10 000 people to come sit and
hear me speak for an hour
i can get thousands of people to read
things that i've written
but what am i doing with that
what's the point what do i really
believe in that i want to use this thing
for
and it was that like you said that
moment of clarity where there was
i was not doing the right things with it
and i had to change it and what i
decided simply was this that all
this 40 years of being an entrepreneur
and all these
tips and tricks and secrets that i
learned to get
startups off the ground were
not surprisingly the exact same tips and
tricks and secrets and approaches and
attitudes
that you could use to get any idea off
the ground
and that all of us have these great
ideas
but that most of us never act on them
and
i decided then and there that that was
my purpose was to
give people that nudge give them that
support give them that encouragement
that says i can do this i can i have
this idea i've always wanted to do this
it doesn't need to be a business it
could be i'd love to live in the city
but i can't afford it how can i figure
this out
love to change jobs how can i make that
happen how do i start
and it led to the book you know that
will never work which
on one hand is the starting and growing
of netflix
but it's really more fundamentally these
lessons about how do you take an idea
and make it real for years i've been
mentoring early stage companies i've
been doing these
hour long advisory calls when people
write me and go i'm struggling with this
with that and i say let's get in the
phone for an hour and let me see what i
can do to help
and about a year ago i began recording
those calls because i thought this might
be interesting to somebody
and it was remarkable because when i did
play these
tapes for people it totally resonated
with them they empathize with the
protagonists who were struggling
some of the tips i was giving them they
could apply to their own stories
and that fundamentally is what led to me
saying this is an opportunity to
actually make it even more broadly
available which is what led to the
that will never work podcast where it's
basically not me
you know interviewing people it's me
just doing what i do
all the time which is helping other
early stage entrepreneurs
take that idea and make it real or take
the idea they've already made real and
bring it to the next level
or turn their side gig into a real gig
it's a it's been remarkable and it's a
it's just so fulfilling in that and it's
to be quite honest it's not entirely
altruistic
i still get now to sit down with people
and sit around that table and solve
these really interesting problems but i
don't now need to
stay until one in the morning working on
it
so that will never work the podcast this
is where you dispense the advice
encouragement and tough love
to an assorted cast of characters
including struggling entrepreneurs could
you give us a
teaser of the format it sounds like it's
conversational
just like these these phone calls that
you recorded
uh can you tell us about any of the
any of the people who who make an
appearance or the types of people
well what's really fascinating is when i
started doing this i kind of
thought i'm gonna run out of topic
that we're going to hear the same things
over and over again uh how do i
wha you know do i do an app or how do i
raise money or
but what you realize is everyone's
struggling with something different
and they're all coming with these
incredibly fascinating businesses
you know one of the young women that i
interview early on is that
she was a worked for a pickup artist for
10 years
you know the kind of people who train
men to pick up women
and she finally said this is totally
awful
and she started a business that helps
people find genuine connection men and
women
and is running these seminars to do that
but was struggling with how to build the
funnel
to end up making this an economically
sustainable business
well that was a fascinating business
another woman runs and
not that this is not the theme so don't
draw too many lines between these
she runs an erotic art gallery online
and selling very very high-end quality
erotic art
but of course the most obvious place for
her to promote
would be social media but she keeps
getting banned
and so she's struggling with how do i
walk that fine line how can i perhaps
lean into this problem and become maybe
a spokesperson for
unreasonable censorship another person
is on the verge of
breaking ground on a sixty thousand
square foot
indoor adventure park in texas with
things like zip lines and repellings
and beer now what could go wrong with
that but
what he what he was calling about
was he realizes that once this thing is
open
that's an 80 to 100 hour work week
how is he going to maintain balance in
his life with all of this happening
it's just they've been they're
remarkable stories they're interesting
people
they're funny and i learn things and i'm
hoping the people who
are listening will not only be
entertained but also
learn something as well sounds
incredible i can't wait to listen
and that will never work can be found
wherever podcasts
are found or is there a particular
outlet is it exclusive anywhere or is it
non-exclusive and ubiquitous well we're
trying to make it ubiquitous but i'm
pretty sure
unless you have some very obscure
podcast platform that you prefer
will you'll find it in all the obvious
places
perfect well i just have maybe one more
question one or two more questions for
you
and this has been so much fun so this is
a question
that sometimes leads to dead end so
it's not always easy to answer but i'll
try it anyway because it's fun
and that is if you had a billboard
metaphorically speaking
on which you could put an image a quote
a question a fortune cookie mantra
anything to get that message to billions
of people
this is assuming they would understand
what's up there
what might you put on such a bill oh god
oh this question you're not going to
believe oh this is real it's
well you know we early on we said we i
would be very
transparent and vulnerable because i
actually i've had this discussion with
my family
um before and a quick background on this
um it doesn't have to be quick i've got
all the time
okay good take your time so four or five
years ago maybe a bit more maybe 10
years ago
i was driving i live in santa cruz
california
which is pretty much the most
politically
left-leaning city in the most
politically left-leaning state
and i was driving by and it was one of
those things where everyone was
protesting
and i can't remember what the issue was
but it was one of those things like you
know
honk if you're for this
but everybody was for that um
and i go why are you if you really
believe so strongly in
in change why are you doing it here
where it's with that issue is going to
win 99 to 1.
why don't you why aren't you going and
doing that on the corner in arkansas
whatever the politically
opposite polar opposite is from
california from santa cruz
um and it gave me an idea uh
as always does when i usually when i
come up with something that's a problem
instantly comes up with the idea and i
was going what if you made a platform
that allowed people to do that
which is they have an issue they feel
strongly about
how could they now express that concern
but do so in a place where it actually
might make a difference
try and advocate for the issue you
believe in a place where that
is actually being contested and i don't
mean
presidential swing state things i mean
small issues
and then i go well a cool thing would be
if these were crowd-sourced campaigns
and i think the way to test it is to do
billboards
that we will do a crowdsourced contest
for this
issue of what the billboards should say
and then people will vote with their
dollars on which billboard
would you understand whoever billboard
wins that all the money flows to that
billboard and then the money goes to
actually running that billboard
someplace else in the country or in the
world
and of course that i didn't go anywhere
but
one of the things we were joking about
is what would be the universal billboard
to put up
and my family
loves these uh types of
exercises because they very quickly
veered toward the absurd so the reason i
was so embarrassed that you asked this
and i will confess what the billboard we
decided we would put up everywhere would
be
and it would largely be to support horse
owners that we
we know and it would say
hoof okay and then a big heart
and then ed you know hoof-hearted
that is the billboard
i can't believe i said that well uh
that's great i'm being transparent
hoof-hearted or hoof love erectile
dysfunction
or there are so many different ways to i
like that it's kind of you have to write
it out it's kind of a rorschach test
it's
yeah it's kind of a worship it's like a
license plate it's a hoof
h o f then a picture of a heart and then
e d
hoof-hearted oh i get it okay oh farting
half-hearted how far to do yeah i
haven't lost hope in this billboard
universal billboard idea
mark i would expect no less from mark
the seagull randall
and uh this has been so much fun i
really appreciate you taking the time
uh and i've i've greatly enjoyed this is
there anything else you would like to
say or share
or request of this audience before we
wrap up any closing comments
at all that you'd like to make certainly
i would i would
really have missed my chance if i didn't
say something to the people who are
listening here
i talked before about what kind of my
whole purpose is trying to give them
people this nudge and
all my years as an entrepreneur all my
you know
six seven companies all the people that
i've worked with all the companies i've
coached
the most fundamental thing i've learned
that separates the people is they start
they stop thinking and they start doing
and if i could encourage
every single person hero has an idea and
i know
you all have an idea i know everyone has
taken a shower has had an idea
but what really separates people is the
ones who actually get out of the shower
and do something about it
to paraphrase nolan bushnell and so
i would just say think about that think
about the next time you have the idea
that you don't
make an excuse that you don't say well i
need a co-founder you know i need an mba
you know i need
financing that's ridiculous if you have
an idea
the only way you're going to find out if
it's a good idea is to do it
so take that swing here here
take that swing randolph.com
that will never work on instagram
twitter mb randolph facebook
mark b randolph linkedin mark
randolph and of course we'll link to all
of these things and more in the show
notes at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast mark thank you so much for all
the time
uh tim it was such a pleasure and uh
thank you so much for the time i really
appreciate it and to everybody
out there listening thank you for tuning
in and until next time
get out there in the world take that
swing
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny
bite of goodness before you head off for
the weekend so if you want to receive
that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this podcast episode
is brought to you by
helix sleep sleep is super important to
me in the last few years
i've come to conclude it is the end-all
be-all that all good things
good mood good performance good
everything seem to stem
from good sleep so i've tried a lot to
optimize and i've tried
pills and potions all sorts of different
mattresses
you name it and for the last few years
i've been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
in like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helix sleep.com
tim take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep
of your life they have a 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free they'll even pick
it up from you if you don't love it
and now my dear listeners helix is
offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim
these are not cheap pillows either so
getting two for free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h e l i x
sleep.com tim for up to 200
off so check it out one more time
helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
tim this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance
i recommended it in fact in the
four-hour body this is more than ten
years ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula
on the market it has multivitamins
multi-mineral greens complex
probiotics and prebiotics for gut health
and immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it
once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course
i focus on nutrient-dense meals to begin
with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around right now
athletic greens is giving my audience a
special offer
on top of their all-in-one formula which
is a free
vitamin d supplement and five free
travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d
i found that true for myself which is
usually produced in our bodies from sun
exposure so
adding a vitamin d supplement to your
daily routine is a great option
for additional immune support support
your immunity gut health
and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
you